on va revenir maintenant sur le fait du
jour euh cette supposée on sait pas
encore agression sexuelle dans une
téléréalité qui passe en ce moment euh
frenchy euh short euh on en a parlé ici
euh si ce soir on en pasle c'est
vraiment parce que cette séquence fait
particulièrement polémique euh Gilles
vous avez tout nous raconter euh avec
Richard euh les téléspectateurs on peut
assister apparemment à une agression
sexuelle dans l'un des épisodes de
téléréalité vous allez nous dire est-ce
que c'est vrai est-ce que c'est faux
regardez euh cette vidéo et là les autes
habitants point du doigt Nico Melvin
était clair qu'il ne voulait pas
embrasser de garçon donc on peut pas lui
imposer de galocher un garçon je
commence à m'imposer et j'ai même pas le
temps de finir que Nico est déjà dans la
bouche de Melvin et là oh mon
[Applaudissements]
dieu W j' es fou ou quoi W j'éta es fou
ou quoi quoi qu'est-ce tuas qu'est-ce
tuas
quoiele vous avez dit pas le
fa qui
ni c'est un jeu j'avais demandé une
seule chose c'était pas d'embrasser des
mecs là franchement ça passe pas je l'ai
là et je suis vir contre tout le monde
vous êtes des fous ah je vous ai prévenu
vous faites les anciens on va voir
maintenant alors j'aimerais qu'on voit
la la séquence parce
que on a l'impression Gilles il ouais
ils étaient les les les les yeux bandés
voulait revoir la séquence en
intégralité ouais parce qu'ils avaient
les yeux bandés et à ce moment-là on
voit ce qui va se passer et ça pose un
vra problème ouis alors regardez vous
dire le problème
[Musique]
ça fou quoi fou quoii
qu'estz j'avais demandé une seule chose
c'était pas d'embrasser des mecs là
franchement ça pass pas je l'ai là et je
suisir contre tout le monde vous êtes
des fous je vous ai
prévenu oui al oui al au départ ça se
veut un jeu ils sont masqués et puis ils
font des choses le problème c'est que
Melvin qui est embrassé donc avait
expressément demandé on le voit après je
ne veux pas embrasser un homme et là
donc il ne sait pas que c'est un homme
qui l'embrasse et on est exactement dans
l'absence de consentement ce qui a fait
une polémique terrible à tel point que
Nicolas celui qui embrasse tu es obligé
de faire un mer à coup et de dire j'ai
commis un acte impardonnable je je alors
c'était quoi le jeu en fait lui c'est
Nicolas qui a décidé de
d'embrerembrasser voilà mais Melvin
avait dit je ne veux pas embrasser un
homme donc du coup la polémique monte
parce que Nicolas a même été obligé
d'employer lui-même le mot agression
sexuelle c'est absence de consentement
donc ça peut s'apparenter à ça voilà et
donc maintenant la production RAM rame
pour tenter de dédramatiser c'est parti
très très vite non mais après la
production elle a rien avoir làdedans
parce que c'est eux qui font le truc ils
vont pas les arrêter tent de
dédramatiseri oui c'est c'est pas de la
faute de la production alors on a
assisté à un échangez lunaire aussi
entre deux candidats dans cette émission
par qu'on a fait une sélection après on
vaevenenir sur sur cette image pour que
vous vous vous voilà vous sentiez un
petit peu ce que c'est que cette
émission qui fait qui révolutionne la
télééalité actuellement il y en a il y a
un qui raconte sa pire expérience
sexuelle avec une fille qui regarder et
l'autre candidat ne comprend pas
l'expression qu'il l'emploi regardez meu
une trace de pneus dans sa culotte du
coup ça m'a dégoûté de ouf et j'ai je me
suis paré gen ça m'a dégoûté genre ça
m'a fait s'est fait rouler dessus une
trace de pneu dans le C dans la culotte
genreun trace de caca quoi ah moi
j'étais sur un pneu de voiture iris
j'aimerais la dévergondée de fou voilà
alors je vous dis al on vous montre
c'est incroyable on a a aussi à des
assist à des soirées vengeance regardez
je vois malvine parler avec une fille au
bout genre de minutes ok tu as lancé les
hostilités je vais répondre avec les
[Musique]
hostilités avec toi Guillaume après faut
quand même relativiser sur ce qui s'est
passé une émission où tous les candidats
ils vont de leur plein gré et la ligne
éditoriale c'est que tout le monde envie
amusé tout le monde a envie de d'avoir
des relations sexuelles ils le disent
eux-mêmes et sur le tournage selon les
infos qu'on a eu nous ça voilà ça a
donné lieu un petite baston mais c'est
des jeunes qui voilà qui font la Pte non
mais non c'est cool he il tu peux pas
non moi je pense que la vérité c'est que
c cet épisode a été diffusé que par
certains ça a été perçu comme une
agressession et qu'après il a été obligé
de mettre un tweet parce qu'il y a eu
certains téléspectateurs qui ont été
outrés la preuve c'est que ça a été
laissé au montage et que ça n'a choqué
personne sur le lieu du tournage ça m'a
été confirmé par des candidats de
l'émission donc faut pas non plus abuser
c'est pas voors ils font des jeux un
petit peu particuliers aussi regardez
c'est je vous le dis on vous montre des
images c'est la c'est une révolution
cetteité c'est comme le loft à l'époque
c'est voilà c'est c'est FO FO 1000
regarde j'ai le jeu des an les garçons
doivent porter un genre de slip avec une
milieu LEGO à TR pas d'intervalle
doivent rentrer les 6 Anau par le B de
leur force qu'ells ont dans le
quoi je sais pas quelle est l'épreuve
mais je je je je la comprends pour vous
est-ce que c'est une agression sexuelle
ici auable Jean-Michel moi non j'appelle
pas c'est un jeu c'est un jeu sexuel non
consenti voilà par l'autre il y a pas
mort d'homme je crois qu'il faut que les
mots ça vous est arrivé vous si ça vous
est arrivé qu' si ça m'est arrivé
j'aurais pas dit j'aurais pas dit que
j'ai été victime d'une agression
sexuelle j'aurais dit tu es lourd
j'avais dit je veux pas de mec comme ça
enfin tu es lourd mais c'est ça je
trouve que pour les femmes qui sont
vraiment victimes d'agression sexuelle
il faut que les mots gardent un sens y a
des hommes aussi qui sont victimes
d'agression sexu s pas contrairecord
c'est pas la majorité quand même il faut
que ça garde un sens un sens dramatique
et là c'est un jeu ils sont tous
qu'on'entend je suis sûr que le soir ils
sont Marés ils on ensemble donc c'est
pas une agression sexuelle dans le sens
moi qui me qui me choque voilà je trouve
c'est un jeu ils sont tous concentant
pour faire les cons ils ont fait le con
par amour propre il a dit oh tu m'as
agressé il sent je pense pas qu'il était
traumatisé vraiment pendant des jours et
des jours s'il l' je m'en excuse je m
suis pas ils ont dit qu'ils étaient à
nouveau amis de gar ils ont enfin celui
qui a été embrassé n'a pas communiqué il
me semble mais celui qui a embrassé à
communiquer en disant on s'en est
expliqué on est à nouveau ami fa rapper
le contexte on n pas sur un li tr on pas
dans la rue c'est des jeunes qui encore
une fois le fait qu'ils allent faire
n'importe quoi ensemble c'est la ligne
éditorale de l'émission je trouve que
parler d'une agression sexuelle pour ça
qu' mal c'est une chose les mot on sens
justement on a une réaction exclusive
les chérriis Melvin ne pouvait pas être
avec nous ce soir nous a donc fait une
vidéo pour s'expliquer ce que je vous
propose on revoit la vidéo comme ça vous
voyez bien qui est melvin et vous allez
voir vidéo exclusive de Melvin pour
s'expliquer donc on revoit la scène et
vous allez voir la vidéo de Melvin juste
après que je vais relancer c'est parti
et là les autres habitants point du Doig
Nico Melvin était clair qu' ne voulait
pas embrasser de garçon donc on peut pas
lui imposer de galocher un garçon je
commence à m'imposer et j'ai même pas le
temps de finir que Nico est déjà dans la
bouche de Melvine et là oh mon
dieu W j'é es fou ou quoi W tu es fou ou
quoi quoi qu'est-ce que tu as qu'est-ce
tuas
quoiele je c'est vous avez dit pas le
faire quo
calal un je j'avais demandé une seule
chose c'était pas d'embrasser des mecs
là franchement ça passe pas je l'ai là
et je suis venir contre tout le monde
vous êtes des fous je vous ai prévenu
vous faites les anciens prve la
nonhomophobie toujours compliqué de se
taper en
slip Melvin on le remercie parce qu'il
nous a fait une vidéo exclusive Melvin
de sa réponse que ça fait énormément de
buzz aujourd'hui cette affaire vous
allez nous dire si après sa vidéo
Melvine AFF faire classer ou pas pour
vous regardez salut à tous cy je peux
pas plate ce soir c'est pour ça que je
te fais cette petite vidéo pour te dire
qu'avec Nicolas tout va bien c'est mon
ami maintenant on s'est expliqué il
s'est excusé donc j'aimerais clore le
débat une bonne fois pour toutes je vous
fais plein de bisous à l'équipe de TPMP
on se dit à plus tard merci Melvin euh
tu es un amour voilà j'espère que tu
viendras nous voir sur le plateau et moi
je vous dis la vérité je je sais pas ce
que vous en pensez est-ce que pour vous
c'est la seule personne importante c'est
la seule personne importante c'est celle
qui se considère ou pas comme une
victime en l'urence consid enregistré il
y a une production jamais il aur diffusé
une agression sexuelle avait été perçu
en tant que tel par les candidat l' très
sympathique en tout voilà et ça n'a pas
été montré en tant que tel dans
l'épisode évidemment je pense que c'est
une réaction de certains internautes qui
ont vu ça qui qui a obligé le candidat à
direis sexu d'ailleurs il a été
relativement intelligent parce que il
n'y a vraiment dans sa réaction aucune
homophobie puis qu'il a bien précisé que
ce n'était pas le fait d'embrasser un
garçon qui le gênait mais le fait de de
qu'on nit pas respecté les règles qu'il
avait mis en place et que c'était voilà
il voulait qu'on respecte ces
règles per à nouveau de parler du
consentement et c'est très bien qu' par
seu c'est un mot qui pèse quand même
exactement c'est ce que disait
Jean-Michel c'est vrai que là tu vois
c'est un peu fort quand même moi je
trouve qu'en 2023 on l' tellement mis en
avant le consentement et c'est bien que
on peut plus enfin ce genre de
comportement c'est plus acceptable pour
Mo co on pouit tout passer on pouit
faire n'importe quoi moi là ça passe pas
après après après on a eu le principal
intéressé qui a dit lui-même que voilà
que c'est il y avait il y avait pas de
il y avait plus de débat entre les deux
J et et voilà après après je pense que
voilà ils ont été pris dans le truc du
jeu de conneries voilà après c'est
Melvin va bien et voilà ils sont devenus
potes c'est l'essentiel parce que ça
fait un buzz incroyable aujourd'hui
merci à tous d'avoir été avec nous tout
de suite moncheville sur C8
merci